i ragazzi avessero video sarò fa vj
grandissimo sul nuovo episodio di testa
sigla
niente serve ragazzi l'ha vinto giugno
da genova che ha fatto un gran
bellissimo video tra l'altro volevo
dirvi se volete vedere i video del gene
tester oltre che i miei video sul canale
di youtube di cartoon network ci sono
tutti i video quindi in descrizione il
canale di cartoon network
detto questo passiamo al gameplay di
oggi che è stephen king force che
pronuncia ragazzi non ci avrete mai più
una pronuncia così ci ha insegnato di
queste parole perché non mi sentirete
mai più nella vita siamo sostenere gli
universi ragazzi che allora di giochini
si chiama guardia guardia capretta che
che anche ha creato questa cosa voglio
saperlo a parte il fatto che io la
capigliatura di steven nelle basette
anche non lei video ma per niente
proprio cioè per non so come si sveglia
la mattina quest'uomo sono stime può
salvare estive il giulia dal tempio
della sulla montagna pericolante ok ed i
tasti freccia percorreva la spaziatrice
come super saltarmi prendi la mela d'oro
per steven giulia prendiamo la mela
d'oro che figo
stavo scherzando non mi piace ma per
niente prova beh devo mi sembrava troppo
semplice devo correre più in prima di
cadere sia posso fare è così ho fatto
probabili di fico si no
qualcuno mi spieghi vi prego anzi no no
non voglio sapere il primo ci siamo
riusciti sono già una camera scusate
devo per riprenderla mele poi tornare ai
geni vada su tutti i blocchi d'oro per
trovare una mela d'oro ok oggi sopra
perfetto contrario avete presente essere
dei pirla ecco non so se riesco a far di
meglio seriamente sta trovando nelle
difficoltà allora ok ok no perché un
gioco per bambini potrei spaventarmi
prefetto è fino a qua c'è poi fanno non
guardarla così ecco i fatti si è girata
male devia importarle lamela perfetto
sì l'ho adorata da e vabbè dai zio non
esiste forse imporsi pianifica
superconti e pianifico a questa l'arma
bay si presume che si debba usare
shabelle non è così scontato se se parli
di me e vendola nelle donne qua ho
capito dove p devo prendere con le
frecce così ci siamo
perfetto come la pillola mela
no dai mi è cascata la bottiglia scusa
mentre scatta pure a furia di girarmi
male un giorno che volerà il pavimento
regata ok ok problemi ragazzi miei
nebera per qua siamo avanzati cerca
stiamo parlando non scarabeo
stai calmo il doppio salto adesso quindi
posso saltare due volte fantasticare
quelli di scarafaggi per ottenere poteri
speciali se non posso saltare due volta
mi rimane anche adesso ce ne sono ancora
ma no velocità più che figo ragazzi sono
andato un fenomeno ne sono il nemico
tutti senza neanche morena volta
provinate ogni provare a tenere record
ferma tempo per tornare in tempo sono
morto rea ci sono neanche arrivato
è
un genio anni come superamento starci
per forza di sapro va bene ok ce l'ho
fatta ho fatto come non è possibile
faremo di essere spacciati simo cos'è
quella roba lì occhio ai pennuti giganti
e mi sono accorto che non dovrebbe
essere proprio maremma
ma se io prendo solo la mela e torno
indietro ma se proprio girato male sto
tizio va beh guarda io tornerei dalla
capra infatti non è così semplice perché
qui uno ci pensa sono giochi per bambini
ma non sono semplici rai ed io ci metto
molto di mio è ok non muoio perché non
sono capace invece no
e invece no ragazzi soggetto mi saranno
le soddisfazioni che lo dico sto
riuscendo a fare cose che non mi so
spiegare a tutti e due velocità il
doppio salto c'è casino proprio bene
roba decente cioè che sono diventato
superman un certo punto ok no a seteco
premuto salta più volte non sapeva sta
cosa
sì ce lo faccio l'angolino sull'angolino
del cratere
va bene siamo quasi alla fine ragazzi
pian piano ci arrivò quasi fosse un
casino ci metterò sei anni però ok
no ragazzi cielo sei ore per prenderla
ma c'e l'occhio e lo successivo ragazzi
stiamo andando
io credo di vincere un premio nobel per
questa cosa
forse no certo dubbio devo saltare ogni
cosa ok fatto perfetto ragazzi un passo
avanti verso la vittoria comunque sono
rapidi ma sono difficili ma devo far
velo lo zio devi fare un ciarlatano o
meno che a meno che a meno che
no no no dai
ma per quale motivo impossibile lo
stesso fatto no no stavolta non lo
accetto giuro mi faccio caso ok ok ok ma
ce l'ho fatta
lo schiaffo e come ci arrivano la
domanda seria è questa come ci arrivo
alla capra che devo fare
no no no no no eh vabbè per arrivare lì
e ci metterò se allora mela cielo no no
no no no no no no ok ragazzi mia data
non bene benissimo se per millimetro e
veloce vero al gemello al cervello o tre
giorni tuo gioco
quest'anno l'ultimo ce l'hai fatta
le stime junior e poi jpj collettive
junior è salvo per ora grazie grazie
sono stato un fenomeno ma solo perché
sono capace a fa ste cose sarà altro che
capra diventa montone ci siamo ragazzi
se non salta gemme che era il videogioco
extensa seguendo un corso intensivo
intestino ho veramente detto il destino
ora intensivo per diventare un eroe
fatto saltare verso l'alto in una
missione di addestramento con la gemma
di cristallo è ok ma sono un fenomeno
stavo morendo mentre stavo dicendo sta
cosa che faccio una partita sola una
questa che state vedendo è l'unica ma
questa sarà l'unica che vincerò
certo sto prendendo ammazzato un cono ai
dettagli
voglio arrivare appena 10mila ho già
deciso non ne faccio altro solo questa
ma questa vico tutto sono scemo e non
avevano mai 10.000 invece sì devo
credere in me stesso la forza è tutta
credere in se stessi ragazzi va bene va
bene va benissimo
bravo bravo bravo bravo forse cia rileva
non basta che non mi faccio più colpire
neanche una volta è già non c'è un modo
per recuperare vita ragazzi qualsiasi
modulo madonna cos'ha fatto
non so come mi se colpisce le mise per
fare tutti a mi fa cadere nuovamente
figata 3.940 le ragazze faccio ancora
una demo riuscì posso battere dire
almeno 5.000 almeno 5.000 anche quelli
pennuto rho e qualche minuto no ragazzi
si cosa ho fatto
si arrivò scialino protezione ci arriva
come rega 5.000 abbiamo detto è
ricordatevelo che per me lo ricordo
sto resistendo ragazzi ma credetemi che
stati è impossibile meno e 44.000 rega
4.000 8.100 4.105 apre impossibile 2
storica trs impulsi come lascia mai
fatto nessuno neanche mi ha creato
soggetto ragazzi accettano scommesse già
faccio noi è certamente di sì 4.800 no
no no fermi ancora parte dei di nucci
dei costi 5000 circa 1200 5400 2006 ciao
ciao sono fa vj sono il fenomeno
comunque è stata affidata ragazzi fatemi
vedere se riuscito a fare di meglio
anche voi se volete fare i take that
mi ricordo che se volete partecipare
come clint ester potete mandare il video
al sito buono molto gatto network.it che
trovate sopra mio bellissimo dita così
potreste diventare voi i prossimi che in
testa del mese quindi fatemi un brivido
ragazzi se volete partecipanti vi
ricordo che questo video potete trovarlo
sia succhiare il gabinetto sia sul mio
canale ossia proprio
canale televisivo di cartoon network
niente ragazzi però capito vi sia
piaciuto e cosa se video è piaciuto sul
commento è un mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook che corrono ai video trovate
nello screenshot sono vestiti semplici
da un motorino belle ragazze